- Unfortunately, my
experience in high school was,
you know not the best
because I had to race against
biological males my
entire high school career.
I lost a lot of opportunities
because I lost four
state championships,
two Alumni awards, and countless
other opportunities to play
and advance and metals.
- I'm Dave Rubin and
we're going to be doing
something a bit different today.
Let me give you a
little backstory here
on May 22nd of this
year USA today put
out an op-ed from
collegiate track star
Chelsea Mitchell about
her experiences competing
against transgender athletes.
However, on May 25th,
just three days later
the publication changed the
word male to transgender
throughout her piece,
without warning
and called her out for using
quote "Hurtful language."
In an editor's note,
the outlet explained
that the op-ed was updated to
"Reflect USA today's standards
and style guidelines.
We regret that hurtful
language was used."
Today I'm speaking
with the author of that
op-ed and her lawyer
please welcome one of the
fastest girls in Connecticut.
Track star Chelsea
Mitchell and her lawyer
who is the general counsel
at the Alliance
defending freedom.
Kristin Wagoner, ladies,
welcome to the Rubin report.
- Thank you.
- All right.
So I'm glad to have
both of you, Kristen.
I reached out to you originally
when I saw this story
on Twitter, because
it just so fit
so many of the things
that I've been talking
about on this show,
Chelsea I'll
I'll start with you since
you wrote the original piece.
Well, I guess first
just tell me how you got
into track and, and, and
you enjoy running, right?
Like that's really
what this is all about.
You want to compete
against girls in running?
- Yeah. I was an
athlete my entire life.
When I got to high school,
I started running track
and I kind of quickly realized
that I was really good at it.
And unfortunately my experience
in high school was,
you know not the best
because I had to race
against, biological males
my entire high school career.
I lost a lot of
opportunities because of them
I lost four state
championships,
two alumni awards,
and countless other
opportunities to play
and advance and metals.
- Right. So when did it
start that biological boys
trans girls were in the
races that you were in?
In girls races.
- Yeah, my freshman year was
when it first started happening
- And, and was it immediate that
they were audit like right out
of the gate, they were faster
and winning all the races
- Right out the gate.
They were still placing
very high in the state.
I was, when I was a
freshman, I placed seventh
at the state open in
the a hundred meters
and one of the biological males
comes in third knocking me
out of the spot to advance in
the New Zealand championship.
- Right. So so what caused
you to write this piece?
And then I'll get to sort
of where the, the legal part
of this is, and then we'll
get Kristen involved.
- I really just wanted
to bring attention to
what has been happening
in Connecticut
because I personally think
it's really unfair to
have biological males raced
against biological
females because we just
cannot keep up with the physical
advantages of a male body.
And so I decided to put
out my own story out
there so that people
could understand what was
happening and how unfair it was.
- And to be clear, I'm
guessing you are not anti-trans
in any way?
- No not at all.
- Put it out there.
Okay. So, so Kristin
when did you get
involved in all of this?
- Well, initially
we filed a complaint
with the department
of education that was
during the Trump
administration in June of 2019.
And as time continued to pass
and we weren't
seeing the department
of ed take substantive
action on it.
We ended up filing a
lawsuit in February of 2020
and that was
Chelsea senior year.
And there were
some circumstances
for her where she was ready
to move forward with that.
And we were glad to assist
because there were four
state championship titles
that she was losing
and it was just coming
to the end where we needed
to get judicial relief.
And so that's why we
filed the lawsuit.
- Right? So Chelsea
what are most people think
sort of behind the scenes?
I, I sense that there's sort
of an activist class and a
a media class that loves
pushing these stories
but the average person that's
going to these track events
and watching you lose to
a biological male probably
gets why you're
upset about this.
- Yeah. I think a lot of people
who have seen this happen
in Connecticut understand
how unfair it is especially
because these biological males
were beating us females by
significant margins in these
races, and it was happening
at every single race we raced
against them, we were losing.
And it was a big difference
and everyone can tell you that.
- Yeah. So, so Kristen,
what do you want legally?
What, what would be right for
to legally happen at this point
- Well there are four
girls that are in the case
in Connecticut, two
who graduated and two remain
in the Connecticut schools.
And so for the two
that have graduated
including Chelsea
and also Selena Soule
those records need to be
corrected in this case alone
it's important to realize
there were two boys
that identified as girls.
One of those boys competed
as a girl three weeks
before he decided to move
over and compete as a girl.
And those two boys
took 15 different races
championships away from girls
during those three seasons.
So there was a huge
impact in Connecticut.
So we want the records
to be set straight.
And then for the girls
that are continuing
and in this Connecticut system
they need to be assured
that they're going to
be biological girls
competing against each other.
And
that it's going to be a fair
playing field moving forward.
- I suspect I know the
answer to this question
but is there any evidence
of biological girls
transitioning to be boys
and then winning in boys sports?
- I, I none that
I can think of any
I'm sure there may be isolated
cases where that's true
but what we do know is
that when boys transition
into the girl sports, there are
hundreds, literally hundreds
of high school boys
that can beat the most
elite female runners
and they have a 10 to
50% performance gap.
So when you're just
looking at averages alone
immediate mediocre male
athlete will almost
always be able to be an
elite female athlete.
- Now Chelsea, if I was to
repeat what Chris had just
said right there
somebody would say you're being
transphobic boys and girls
men and women are
exactly the same.
Do you concede that there are
some biological differences?
- Of course there are
biological difference
between males and females.
That's why we have
sex separated sports.
I mean, you know
it's kind of hard to
just put biological male
female category
and say that it's
not an issue when
I know so many boys
in the state
could easily beat me
and they would not win
the state championship
if they were in
the boy category.
- Right. So what
would you prefer that
that those trans athletes do
should they have their
own division altogether
or you would just prefer
that, okay, you were born male
you should just be competing
with the, with the boys
regardless of how you
feel about yourself.
Something like that.
- I think the most
important thing is to
protect the female
category and make sure
that us females are
having a fair competition.
And I think that should be
the number one priority.
- Right? Kristen, what'd
you make of a USA today
switching some of
the language here.
I mean, once you submit an
op-ed, you know, I, you know
Chelsea wrote a piece that
was honest and heartfelt
and then suddenly it's not just
that they're changing language.
The implication is somehow
that what Chelsea was
saying was somehow hateful.
- It was shocking to us.
I mean, we, we write
op-eds all the time.
Our clients are writing
op-eds and we can't think
of any other instance
in the 30 year history
we've been involved
in public interest law
where they have felt
like they could change
what someone else wrote
without even advanced notice.
Like, we didn't get
a call that said, Hey
just want you to know
this just happened.
And it's just, it's shocking
in terms of the lack
of journalistic integrity,
and also the accusations
because nothing could be
further from the truth.
- Right? Well, is there any
is there any legal recourse
you can take with them on that?
I mean, the idea that they
changed it three days later
implying that somehow
the policy changed as
if they didn't read
it in the first place.
- There probably is, but
I don't know that we're
as interested in
that is making sure
that the public knows that
this language isn't appropriate
that what USA has done is USA
today has done isn't right.
And winning this
case for our girls
I mean girls should
have equal opportunities
the same opportunities
that their brothers have
and they need to be
authentic and real.
And that can't happen
when male bodied athletes
are competing in
the girls category.
- Chelsea, can you
just talk a little bit
about what it's like to
be a young person going
through the mob and the,
and the monster that so
many people fear that
that's really why I reached
out to Kristen originally
when I saw this
because I just saw, oh
here's just a nice
girl who wants to run
and tell her story, that's it.
And then of course you read
the stuff that they're saying
about you and about you
Kristin, and all the rest of it.
And it's just, it's just
nothing to do with the truth.
- It's really frustrating
especially because this
is just about the boys, you
know the biology matters
in sports and I think that
t's really obvious to a lot
of people so you know I'm
not trying to be harmful
in any way, I just want
to be able to run on a
fair playing field.
- Yeah. But what about
getting all the mean tweets?
Not fun, right?
- No, but you know,
you always got to look
at the support instead
of all the mean tweets.
- Yeah. Kristen,
are you seeing this?
You guys are in Connecticut
but are you seeing this
like all across the country?
There's so many cases that
sounds so similar to this.
- Absolutely. We
have a case in Idaho.
I mean, it is, you've probably
seen, there've been 30
some different state
proposals that were just
proposed this last year
because we are seeing it happen
across the United States.
I've seen it on my
own daughter's teams
in conservative Arizona
softball as well a
soccer we've had
volleyball teams that have
called us where literally
a girl got a concussion
from being hit
with a guy playing.
And, and of course
they're playing on
the lower nets, right?
And then we have the Idaho case
which where the ACLU
immediately brought suit
challenging a law that
protected women in that state.
And they're trying
to get it struck
down at the night circuit.
And we represent
two track athletes
at the collegiate level
in that case as well.
- I'm actually glad that
you brought that case
up because I was going
to bring that up.
But what has happened to
the ACLU that was once
the great defender of civil
liberties in the United States
and now is, is actually
attacking women in essence.
- It's horrific.
I mean, it's just so stunning
when you think about the fact
that the ACLU would go after,
you know, with defend those
in Skokie so many years ago,
and yet on free speech matters
they don't believe in
free speech anymore.
And we used to be able
to say that, you know
we would defend
to the death, you
for your free speech rights,
even if we disagree with you.
And that used to be
the ACLU's position
but they've abandoned it long
ago in favor of ideology.
I will say though
that there is a broader
coalition that's
supporting Chelsea.
And this issue,
there are, you know
feminists that are coming out
and saying, this is not right.
And we're thankful for them.
We might not align with
them on other issues.
But man, where we do align
is that biology matters.
And that we're
setting women back
by allowing men to
call themselves women
and compete against women
in their own categories.
- Chelsea, I can sense you're,
you're wired sort of cool
which I like here, but
can you talk a little bit
about like what it's like
to just be a young person
in this like bizarrely
polarized political time
and all of this stuff, you know
transgender athletes
in critical race theory
all of these things that
I'm sure your friends
are talking about, and
it's gotta be just like
a rough time to be in
high school and college
right now.
- It's definitely hard,
especially on this topic
because I really believe
that biological position
causes unfairness in sports
you know, an issue that
should be pretty clear
obvious has been
very politicized
and it's definitely very
frustrating to have it
be that way when I don't
think it should be.
- Yeah, Kristen, is
that the bizarre part
that this doesn't
feel like the type
of thing you should
even be having to deal
with as a case at some
level like 10, 15 years ago
this never would have
probably got to your desk?
- No, it wouldn't have, I mean
there are so many conversations
that we have, you know
among our 70 attorneys.
It's like, I can't
believe we have to go in
and argue about body
parts in the courtroom
and say that they matter or,
or that someone would say
that saying a biological
male is biological
male is harmful
or hurtful speech.
And this is just common sense
in the science does support it.
So we believe that in the
end, it's an important issue
for the protection of our
women and our daughters.
And it's those, it's
the female athletes
and women that are going to
suffer the brunt of this harm
if we lose these biological
differences in the law.
- Yeah. Has that
been the weird part
for both of you
guys that, you know
the side that keeps
saying science matters is
actually being quite
anti-science right now
that that must be
strange for you, Chelsea.
- Yeah. It's definitely
frustrating to hear them kind of
you know not acknowledge
the science behind biology.
- Yeah. Well, how can we
how can we shed
further light on this?
How can we help
you guys, Chelsea?
Where can I direct people to
if they want to support
you, support the cause
- You know, I just think
spreading awareness
about this issue
and have conversations
about it is definitely good
because I want people
to understand what's
really happening
and that this is an
unfair situation.
- Yeah. All right, Kristen
we're going to direct
the people to you.
That's probably a better idea.
We'll we'll link to
your Twitter down below
but for people that
want to get involved.
Cause I know there's a lot
of people they want to
donate to the right causes.
You know, they, they used
to maybe donate to the ACLU
but they don't want to anymore.
They want to help
the lawyers that are
on the front lines of
this. What can people do?
- Well, certainly we
all of our services
to our clients or pro bono
and we would appreciate the
support we've been leading
on the issue in terms
of the litigation
but also the legislative
work we've been in all
of these states and eight
states have passed bills so far.
So that's one thing
but I want to really
encourage grassroots support
in your own backyard.
I mean, these things are
happening in our school boards.
The same philosophy is you
already linked it with CRT.
We need to be active when these
kinds of policies are passed
because they pass them
under the dark of night.
And we need to be adapt to those
and have the courage to speak
out in our own communities.
And also to be looking out
for those like Chelsea who
are caught in the crosshairs
give them words of encouragement
because they feel isolated
and they are attacked.
And so that those words
of encouragement are
really helpful too.
- Well, Chelsea
you're brave, you're
doing the right thing.
And if you ever
make it out to LA
and you want to run a race
with a 44 year old guy
with a torn ACL in his left
knee, I could give it a go.
It probably will
not end well for me.
- Thank you,
- Kristen.
We'll, we'll link to some
of your stuff down below
so people can, can find
out more about the law firm
and what you guys are doing.
And I thank you guys for
taking the time and oh
well I guess I should ask
one other question, which is
I assume you tried to
contact the USA USA today
and say, guys, this is not cool.
What did they say? Did
they even get back to you?
- We did have a conversation.
I didn't have that conversation,
but our media team did.
And as you can
see, it's still up.
So they did not fix it.
And that's deeply,
deeply concerning
for the future of journalism.
- Yeah. That's a whole other
story that I cover here
pretty much every day.
Well, Chelsea, Kristin,
I thank you guys.
And we'll, we'll keep watching.
- Thank you.
- All right. Take care.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about women's issues instead
of nonstop yelling checkout
our women's issues playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out our full episode playlist
they're both right over here
and to get notified
of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.